starting with the president
broadcast live to the nation with
shaking hands
indonesia's kovid 19 vaccinations began
but here they're doing something
different to most in the west
using chinese jab cenovac and
vaccinating
under 60s first we will protect them
from the coffee 19 which means they can
of course doing economically
and then secondly by protecting this age
group
we will cut the transmission
boosting indonesia's economy isn't the
only reason under 60s go
first here the government's also waiting
for more
safety data about how sinovac affects
the elderly
beginning with frontline workers the
president wants to vaccinate more than
181 million people
this year that's almost three times the
size of the uk
population
in jakarta where the jab is mandatory
some are skeptical i feel that
those people the productive people they
could wait
because they're not the one risking
their lives first
the elderlies are the ones at stake
right now
the fourth most populous country in the
world
many here are struggling before covert
19 this catering company
sold more than 200 meals a day
these days it's dropped
[Music]
indonesia says sinovac is around 65
effective and can be kept in the fridge
it is buying other brands
but the chinese could deliver fastest
while many in the west are focusing on
vaccines from europe and america
here in asia countries including
thailand indonesia
and the philippines will all start with
cenavac
china has deliberately positioned itself
to fill a gap in the market
and supply developing countries who
otherwise
would face a long wait experts say
it's textbook pandemic politics
diplomacy has become one of the tools
for big country to to improve and
increase their their power in the region
of course china will use this as their
people must see power
uh that's for sure but with more than
270 million people to protect
and surging cases this is a power game
indonesia is willing to play siobhan
robbins
sky news